aa c'est une affirmation qui est
totalement vrai c'est faux big up à mon
père a pris
[Musique]
c'est vrai il y a eu des actrices plus
jeunes comme moi notamment isabelle
adjani qui a est rentré je crois à 16
ans alors qu'elle était venue
accompagner quelqu'un mais par contre
dans la catégorie masculine
effectivement je suis le j'ai été le
plus jeune pensionnaire de la comédie
française
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai que la
cuisse est puisqu'il vous permet de vous
corriger c'est une cuillère fourchette
fort qui dans toy story 4 c'est un de
mes plus grands rôles avec peut-être
hippolyte dans phèdre que j'ai joué la
comédie française
d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
similitudes entre les deux rôles
je n'ai pas de chiqué mais je pense que
ça me paraît probable que ça arrive dans
ce temps voilà c'est vrai battre après
pierre et vacances c'était un début dans
ma vie un des deux buts de ma vie ouais
c'était un tracteur est très très proche
de pierre et vacances dans tout ce
qu'elle gorrite
en fait c'est à la base ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'on m'a proposé mes agents
américains nous proposer passés les
essais pour spider man est en fait j'ai
dit oui grave
moi je suis peter parker depuis que je
suis née je suis je voue un culte à
absurde et absolue à spider man mais
quand ont ils m'ont dit par contre
sachez que si tu passe les essais et
qu'il ya un deuxième tour et tout
commence à s'engager dans un processus
où marvel met la main sur toi et si
jamais tu fais le film faut signer pour
six sept huit ans d'une des franchises
avec eux et ça m'a fait très peur et je
me suis en fait j'ai pas envie de ça on
propose des trucs super et variés
différents et riche en france et donc
j'ai dit non au casting casting vous
l'aurez bien compris vous n'aurez jamais
été pris pourquoi est-ce qu'ils seraient
venus chercher
pierre niney qui tombe juste après
pierre et vacances sur google
c'est vrai je suis passé par cette phase
mais c'est juste parce que j'étais
fasciné par le casque où on ne les voit
pas c'est un miroir de dehors mais le
vois de l'autre côté très bizarre à
venir je ne sais pas ce que ça raconte
deux mois big up à monter rap east j'en
ai rêvé un moment après j'ai rêvé d'être
pilote d'avion pendant assez longtemps
pilote de ligne et puis après j'ai
découvert que j'étais myope daltoniens
nuls en maths ça faisait beaucoup pour
être pilote et que les gens soit en
sécurité
consult sous le nom de notre père juif
et de la terre thérapie par les
mutations qui est très très efficace et
qui a fait ses preuves
voilà oui oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que je perds ça marche surtout sur
jonathan cohen
c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai la chance
d'avoir une voix avec un métier public
qui porte un tout petit peu plus que
d'autres voient donc j'essaye de parler
de choses qui me paraissent est
importante
comme par exemple ce petit truc qui
pourrait être la survie de l'humanité et
de la planète terre en bresse ça me
touche beaucoup et j'en parle
nan nan c'est dur non c'est dur parce
que je préfère largement françois civil
donc c'est dur de mentir et de vous dire
que c'est déjà un temps quand même
jonathan c'est un tire-au-flanc
c'était évidemment mes idoles comme
beaucoup de français pas une grande
originalité mais je pense que c'est
légitime parce que c'est un immense
animal acteurs créatures de comédie
c'est devenu feyman bientôt en battle
avec hubert bonisseur de la bath oss 117
mais j'aime beaucoup fame and et
j'aimerais un jour peut-être qu ils se
décrochent d'un arbre et qu'il vole de
ses propres ailes
tout à fait adrien gallo que j'embrasse
adrien écrivait ses chansons en cours de
physique chimie à queue à côté de moi on
était très très potes et je me rappelle
qu'ils remplissaient le gibus à l'époque
ce qui était déjà pas mal c'était un
petit groupe bb brunes qui commençait
mais moi j'avais dit ouais les gars pour
le charrier je l'aï dit appelle moi
quand tu remplir un zénith là on parlera
à tous et six mois plus tard il faisait
le zénith c'était aller très très vite
[Musique]